Hm.
What's the topic of today's video?
No,
that's far too general.
it's not that either.
No,
I already made a video on that one.
Yes,
that's it.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the
Russian language.
Why is Russian important?
Well,
Russia is one of the world's major
languages.
It is one of the six official languages
of the United Nations and it is the
eighth most widely spoken language in
the world with around $155 million
native speakers and around 260 million
speakers in total.
If we include second language speakers.
It's an official language in Russia of
course,
but also in Belo Reus,
Tajikistan,
Kurgestan and Kazakhstan.
It is also an official language and 38
other unrecognized states,
autonomous territories and regions in
Ukraine,
Moldova and Georgia,
and also a few localities in Romania and
the Russian economic zone in Spitsbergen
in Norway.
It is also widely spoken as a second
language on a Lingua Franca,
throughout much of Central Asia,
the Caucasus region,
and in eastern Europe.
Even in a lot of places where it is not
an official language,
that's why Russian is important.
Russian is the most widely spoken
language of the Slavic language family.
Have a look at my video on the Slavic
language family here to learn more about
it in detail,
but in brief the Slavic languages or a
branch of the Indo European language
family and the beginning of the Slavic
language.
Branch traces back to a language called
Slavek,
which existed around 500 ce.
Over the next few hundred years,
Prodo slavek split into three varieties,
west Slavic,
south Slavic and east Slavek,
which eventually diverged into branches
of the Slavic language family containing
numerous languages.
Each Russian is an East Slavic language,
along with Belorussian Ukrainian,
and also routine at the time that these
three branches developed,
there was a single slavic literary
language that all Slavs could understand
that language was old church slavonic.
Russian has written in the cyrillic
script,
which was created for the purpose of
writing old church slavonic until the
14th century.
The ancestors of modern day Russians,
Ukrainians,
and Belarusians living in a state called
Kevin.
Russ spoke dialects of old East Slavic.
The spoken language existed alongside
the literary language of Old Church
Slavonic,
a situation of glossier.
There is,
however,
some evidence that people used to write
in the spoken vernacular for some kinds
of casual writing.
Birchbark letters from the town of
Nevada road in the 14th century are
written in the vernacular language and
the concern topics of daily life.
Old Church slavonic,
however,
it was the literary and religious
language in the 13th century CE Kevin
risk was conquered by the Mongol Empire,
which brought a lot of foreign Turkic
loan words into the East Slavic dialect,
especially words related to political
and financial matters.
After the end of Mongol rule,
in the 14th century,
the oldest Slavic area was split into
two separate states,
the Grand Duchy of Moscow to the east
and the Grand Duchy of Lithuania to the
West in the general area of Ukraine,
Belarus,
and Lithuania.
The oldest Slavic dialects in those two
states began to split and develop in
different directions.
In the West,
the Ruthenian language emerged with
heavy Polish influence,
Ruthenian dialects would later develop
into Ukrainian and in in the east
Russia,
and emerged with much more influence
from old church slavonic.
Modern Russian today resulted from a
kind of tug of war between an old church
slavonic on the one hand and the
vernacular spoken dialects on the other
hand.
For example,
in 1453 ce,
after the fall of the Byzantine Empire,
Byzantine and Bulgarian scholars began
moving to Moscow and they were upset
that old church slavonic had become
corrupted or crucified,
and they tried to standardize the
language to remove these impurities.
So a unique Russian language had begun
to emerge,
but scholars pulled the language back
towards old church slavonic.
But then during the rule of Peter the
great from 1696 to 1725,
the written language was pulled in a
different direction away from old church
slavonic.
In order to increase literacy,
he simplified the orthography of the
written language,
eliminating some letters and some
diacritics.
He also made great efforts to modernize
and westernize Russia and started to
Orient Russia towards Europe and French
became the common language of the upper
classes in Russia.
As you might guess,
this resulted in the adoption of some
French loan words into Russian.
He also oversaw the intentional adoption
of specialized modern vocabulary from
various European languages like French,
Dutch,
and German.
Peter,
the great's reforms were some of the
first steps in the development of modern
literary Russian,
the basis of standard Russian today,
another influential person in the
development of modern literary Russian
was Mikaila Luminoso in 1755.
He wrote a grammar of the Russian
language which revolutionized the
written language by combining old church
slavonic with the spoken language
throughout the grammar.
He refers to old church slavonic as the
language of high style and he refers to
the spoken language as the language of
low style and he advocated a blended
middle style for most forms of writing.
The high style was basically reserved
for religious texts and the low style
was reserved for the most casual written
material in the following decades.
Authors and poets developed a new middle
style that would form the core of modern
standard Russian.
The most influential was the poet
Alexander Pushkin,
who was sometimes referred to as the
father of the modern Russian language.
He fully developed the idea of three
different language registers,
high,
middle and low,
making the spoken vernacular,
a legitimate part of the language.
He also greatly expanded the vocabulary
of literary Russian by directly
translating phrases and idioms from
other languages.
He greatly influenced modern literary,
Russian,
and as a result of modern standard
which formed during this time based on
the literary language
in the 20th century,
Russian underwent some small changes
mainly in orthography,
but by far the most important thing to
happen to the language was the creation
of the Soviet empire,
universal schooling and the mass media
spread,
modern standard Russian and reduced
dialectal variation in Russian.
It also spread the language over a vast
geographic area covering all the member
states of the USSR.
Today,
Russian is still widely spoken in all of
those areas and is a common lingua
Franca between different ethnic groups
and between the citizens of different
countries.
So what does Russian like orthography
Russian is written in cyrillic script,
an alphabet consisting of 33 letters
which were mostly developed from Greek
letters,
some of the same as letters of the Latin
alphabet,
but some of the sounds they represent
are different like this one
phonology.
There are 21 consonants in Russian,
but 15 of them can be pronounced in two
different ways,
either hard or soft,
and you have to judge which sound to
make by looking at the letter that comes
after the continent.
The soft sound is palletized,
meaning that part of your tongue reaches
the roof of your mouth.
This makes the consonant kind of sound
like it's followed by a y sound.
Here are some examples.
Buck,
buck,
buck model,
mel pro suck,
suck vowels.
There are six basic vowels in Russian,
but there's a lot of variation in the
vowels depending on the surrounding
sounds and based on the stress pattern
of the work that wills are often reduced
when they appear in an unstressed
syllable.
This can make it a challenge to
pronounce words correctly based on their
spelling.
Grammar.
Russian is a fusional language,
meaning that suffixes and prefixes are
added to root words to communicate
grammatical meaning.
Let's look at nouns first.
There are six now in cases in Russian,
meaning that both the singular and the
plural form of unowned can't take six
different forms depending on their
grammatical function in the sentence.
Let's look at an example using the word
for sister nominative case.
Sister,
the sister reads genitive case since
three years now,
misses three.
I know the sister's name,
date of case series three.
Sister,
the brother gave the sister a ticket.
Accusative case says through visits,
through the brother sees the sister.
Instrumental case says Roy Roy,
I live with the sister.
Prepositional case says three masses on
the sister.
On a side note,
it's interesting to notice the cognate
vocabulary between Russian and English
and some other European languages.
Just the his sister,
his brother mediate his ticket,
and even the word foresee reminds me of
the Italian word Vedanta,
which means to see.
So here we see some clear indications of
Russian being an Indo European language.
Now,
back to the noun cases.
The case endings are different depending
on the gender of the now.
Russia nouns are grouped according to
gender,
with masculine,
feminine and Neuter Nouns.
You can normally tell the nouns gender
based on its ending.
Feminine Nouns can take either of these
endings,
neuter.
Nouns can take either of these endings
and masculine nouns.
The nouns ending in any other letter.
The one tricky exception is that some
nouns and in this letter,
and these can be either masculine or
feminine,
so you need to memorize the gender of
those ones.
Adjectives,
adjectives and Russian are quite
complicated.
They are inflicted to agree with the
Noun they modified in gender number and
in case that means that any particular
adjective can 24 different forums like
this.
Wow.
Let's look at a couple of examples.
This is the adjective meaning new in the
nominative case.
No Hilton over here.
This is a new car in the genitive case,
Nova,
Nova.
After my Buddha,
the new car's color so we can see how
the ending of the adjective changes to
make it agree with the noun,
but it's worth noting that the
inflectional endings added to the
adjective or different from those added
to the now,
so you need to memorize a big set of
endings for nouns and when to use them,
but you have to memorize a whole
different set of endings for adjectives
and when to use those verbs.
The Russian language has three verb
tenses,
past,
present,
and future.
That sounds straightforward,
but Russian verbs are also distinguished
based on something called aspect.
There's the perfective aspect,
which means that an action has been
completed once.
Then there's the imperfection of aspect
which shows that the action is still in
progress,
still ongoing,
or that it's an action that will be
recurring,
will be repeated many times in Russian
verbs.
There are two different verb stems for
the imperfections and the perfect
aspect,
basically like two different words.
Let's look at an example for the verb
meaning to write first.
The perfective visa and the imperfection
of Pisa.
Either of these stems can be conjugated
for past,
present,
and future tenses.
Let's look at an example of how aspect
changes the meaning of a sentence.
This sentence uses the verb with
perfective verb stem and is in the
future tense.
Yanna.
Can you go this sentence means I will
write a book,
but when we take the aspect into account
that the meaning is I will write one
specific book and action that will be
completed.
This next sentence uses the imperfection
verb stem and is also in the future
tense.
Besides the meaning of this one is more
like I will be writing a book.
In other words,
I will be in the process of writing a
book at a certain time in the future or
if we use the plural form of book,
then the meaning changes.
It means I will write two books Jambo
besides,
and that means I will write numerous
books of recurring action.
So in that case,
the imperfection of aspect indicates a
slightly different meaning.
Basic word order the most common word
order in Russian as Svo,
but because of the case system,
the word order is much more flexible
than it is in English and English.
We normally judge the function of a word
depending on where it is in the
sentence,
but in Russian we have the case system.
The case endings can tell us the
function of the word so you can move the
words around and we still understand
what the subject is,
what the object is and so on.
So a basic sentence might be of course
gripped by Malama,
meaning the cat caught the most,
but you could also have much by molecule
or by Mahler,
Gorshkov and some other possible word
orders,
so the basic word order is flexible like
that.
However,
in some cases the context or the style
that you are trying to communicate it
and will determine the word order
articles,
like most Slavic languages,
Russian doesn't have any articles.
It doesn't have words like [inaudible]
or the.
If you have any Russian speaking friends
who dropped the articles when they're
speaking English,
that's probably the reason.
So how hard is rushing to learn?
Well,
according to the American Foreign
Service Institute,
Russian is a category four language,
the most difficult categories,
category five,
and that includes Japanese,
mandarin,
and Arabic,
but Russian is in category four.
That means that it's relatively
difficult for English speakers,
but not the most difficult.
The most challenging things will likely
be the inflection of nouns and
adjectives as well as the system of
verbal aspect.
Some people mistakenly assume that the
cyrillic alphabet is going to be the
most challenging part of learning
Russian,
but people actually learn that fairly
quickly once they start rushing as a
major global language.
That will be very useful to you if you
spend any time in Russia or in any of
the former Soviet republics.
So your efforts will be well rewarded.
So the question of the day,
for people who have studied Russian,
what did you find challenging about
Russia and what did you find
straightforward about Russian and for
native speakers of Russia?
Russia is a huge country.
Do you notice a lot of variation in the
way that Russia has spoken in different
parts of the countries?
Are there noticeable accents or dialects
these days?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on twitter,
on facebook,
and on Instagram,
and thank you to all my patrion
supporters.
You guys continue to be great and I
appreciate you.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.